la protesta en las calles continua
porque los peruanos se resisten a
aceptar la legitimidad del denominado
gobierno de transición el objetivo de
miles de ciudadanos que toman las calles
es conseguir que se vaya manuel merino
la marcha está constituida en su mayor
parte por jóvenes quienes denunciaron la
infiltración de agentes de inteligencia
de la policía y en las anteriores
movilizaciones su presencia ha sido
duramente cuestionada precisamente a la
organización de las naciones unidas le
pidió a la policía peruana de hacer las
detenciones con policías vestidos de
civiles y aún no recordó las autoridades
que deben de abstenerse de usar la
fuerza de manera ilegal excesiva o
arbitraria a pesar de la represión
policial los manifestantes salen a las
calles y afirman que las protestas
continuarán y no descartan hacer
vigilias al respecto el presidente
manuel merino dijo que la actual crisis
política que ha detonado en asia
con tracción al poder no es
responsabilidad del gobierno de
transición y lo responsabilizó a la
pandemia kobe 19 la recesión económica y
el desempleo anunció que en las próximas
horas presentará un programa de medidas
para atender a la población